i feel like i'm late to the web 3.0
stuff that's the feeling i got when i
was reading about that stuff i was like
damn i slept on this for like years
yeah i mean there's so much [ __ ]
happening already have you ever looked
at like the stack
of like web 3.0 like how like like you
know like
when you think of like web stack it's
like you see like the layers it's like
backhand
front end whatever like i was looking at
some diagram that was
detailed about the web 3.0 stack like
where crypto falls in and where
other like smart contracts and stuff fit
in and
it was like seven layers bitcoin was
layer
one and then ethereum was layer two
oh i see so it's like this is just
trying to say in the bonus
yeah and then there's a d5 or there's a
decentralized database
technology that people use yeah that's
like way up okay um
but and then web host
yeah dns there's a decentralized dns now
[ __ ] is like
that's the stuff that's like gets higher
yeah but
when i i feel like i didn't articulate
this very well on the bonus so it's
weird to do it now
but you know
to the point of people being like why do
you guys talk about crypto so much dude
it's gonna it's gonna shift the paradigm
man yeah
serious cody paradigm shift co
literally you can call me that i mean uh
i'll shut the [ __ ] up about it but
yeah i love talking about this [ __ ] i
mean dude the concept of
it's how it's the total inverse of
everything now
everything now it's like one person
contains and owns everything and decides
everything
and this the idea of like tick-tock
a like a social platform being
completely decentralized with like
capability of an
anonymous it's scary as [ __ ] as what it
is yeah that's what i was talking about
before it's like
then how do you actually prevent because
okay okay so there's some level to like
uh
there's some argument right where it's
like no censorship right like
whether or not you think it's good or
bad that trump got taken off of twitter
right whatever there's a lot of people
that think that censorship that
shouldn't happen and so with a design
decentralized system it can't happen
yeah but then how do you
how do you block out the truly evil [ __ ]
not to say trump isn't true
truly evil but i'm saying like the
crimes and oh yeah and like
people sharing nefarious horrible [ __ ]
yeah it's gonna be like
fortune imagine a decentralized 4chan i
mean
yeah where you can never take anything
down yeah so then
how do you police that you need to a
little bit of regulation is good that's
why we have speed limits and sea
what i'm saying balls you speed limit on
the internet to stop all these
[ __ ] pedophiles well i'm pretty
that's pretty much what it is like
no yeah and i mean even
like people that trade that info like
i was talking about like zero knowledge
protocol like yeah the fact that you
could
be a disgusting person and confirm that
with someone else who's like about that
yeah and like you guys can now
anonymously
share information and data
yeah so wild man but yeah that
that that future of
privacy going from
totally at risk to uh
impenetrable like you can be as private
and as masked as you want
i was thinking of [ __ ] like imagine face
filters get so good and voice filters
get so good that like
what if social apps are just like it's a
grown man being charlie demilio
yeah yeah and then he goes out in his
regular life and no one has a [ __ ]
clue
yeah and then he works with a team to
manufacture media and
what if it's sharp as [ __ ] and people
just believe it yeah it will be that
and then you know because it'll be in vr
too you could do that just
yeah i was picturing like imagine some
scary like
private resort where it's like required
at all times to like wear some like
ar headset and you can never know who's
actually there
like imagine like going out to a
restaurant and then like because you
have your ar
on everyone's face is like muted in some
way oh like they're all in like
uh those like masks those like
uh phantom of the opera masks type yeah
basically that but like the tech version
yeah that's just i don't know
i don't know just the future man the
future that's all i was thinking about
that's right it sounds like you were
relaxing yeah
relaxing thinking about this stressing
the [ __ ] out over there absolutely
over what's gonna happen in five years
paradigm shift
nah just it just made me think how we
you know it made me think on
the way we talk about krypton and stuff
i think the narrative is kind of dumb
you know it's just it's all purely about
the financial stuff and
we sleep on the other part of it which
is no did the technology that people are
experimenting with on
the back end oh yeah is the part that
like when we talk about it made me feel
that when we talk about ai
and the takeover of robots and stuff
that's like we think that of physical
things like being replaced by machines
and whatever and
i look at the web 3.0 i'm like no no
dude
this is the weird ai world yeah that's
going to take over
yeah where you know transactions and
data and all that stuff is being
crunched and produced by obscure
machines
in like people's backyards and they
don't even know that it's here
you know what i mean like it's just that
that's the
bizarro world we're going into it which
is why
dude this is why it's so these like [ __ ]
coins are so annoying because it's like
there's so much
incredible [ __ ] happening and the world
is
changing like blockchain could be the
and bitcoin could be the most important
invention of the last
however many years you know what i'm
saying yeah and
yet boob coin
boob coin yeah is the thing that
everyone's paying attention to
yeah you know the shiba inu coins yeah
they get ripped off and they're like you
know what [ __ ]
crypto crypto's for losers man
it's going away the only thing that has
to be fixed is
the chain making changes on a blockchain
whoever figures that out wasn't marcus
working with some people
you can't do it that's the point no but
uh
sorry in in relation to like dapps like
decentralized apps like
it's if you put out a dap like it's kind
of
that's what smart contracts are for
right yeah but there's still a degree of
like
um limitation that's why dowels and
stuff
are super experimental and they have
very specific use cases because
it's hard to iterate so whoever can
figure out some weird
middle layer there that's gonna be like
the
what yeah but yeah okay last thing i'll
say
sorry the did you look at that whole
[ __ ] uniswap
yeah and you saw how like they forked
and that whole business
no i didn't all right so i read this
article or someone was basically talking
about how like
if you consider smart contracts to be
the basis of like a company or like an
organization
there's like a world where people could
fork your company
yeah oh yeah yeah like someone could
wake up one day and be like draftking
sucks i could do it better
and fork the whole thing and then
that's [ __ ] awesome man you're just
media too oh yeah you're like
i could fight better than podcasting
podcasts they talk about crypto too much
i'm gonna fork it
let's do a good [ __ ] yeah i'm gonna
yeah i'm gonna synthesize all voice
recordings of them and build the same
podcast but better
but better could you imagine selling
like like
specific iterations of your personality
like as a podcast yeah
yeah so we took all our voices and now
we're manufacturing a finance podcast
but it's us what the [ __ ] yeah sorry
so yeah you know relaxing [ __ ] i i will
take another pina colada
yeah you know what yes i'll have another
opinion yeah uniswap was crazy man
yeah that i mean that whole um
basically what it was guys is uniswap
was like a
it was a smart contract for nft
uh trading right like it would find like
a buyer and a seller
yeah yeah it's a exchange right it
actually wasn't like a full
exchange it just like because i don't
think any of the nfts lived on uniswap
in the beginning gotcha it they do now
okay
so here's what's crazy is it started as
a smart contract which is kind of like a
brokering system this is my
understanding and then sushi swap came
along
they took that smart contract and they
go we're going to build a company out of
this
so then the people who created that
smart contract for unit swap they're
like
nah and then they made their platforms
then they launched
essentially two companies like i don't
know the timeline but essentially in
tandem oh okay
and it's just like out of a smart
contract two companies were born and
like they're
in some way competing wow and then they
are
daos so they offer you can stake in the
company
so you can uh benefit from the
profits they take from people buying and
selling nfts by buying tokens by buying
uniswap so you can
you can be invested in the company and
be like essentially in control of it so
you can vote
and participate yeah by buying unit swap
token right no
so it's like that's the other thing is
there's two instruments where if you
stake you do get tokens
but you can also buy tokens in the
company but not be staked
oh okay i see so damn
yeah if that should and that
that like the numbers they make they
make like the double digit millions like
daily oh yeah dude the [ __ ] so i'm
investing monthly sorry not daily
uh i'm investing in this fund that just
does crypto investments
and their their first fund they invested
in uniswap and it's like
38 000 return on their investment or
something absurd
is it just like a public fund or no it's
like a it's like a private
thing damn i was looking at like auto
yield
funds and stuff those are crazy as well
but so yeah there's so much like
interest
[ __ ] happening right now too like
staking and collecting interest on
like all my friends are staking their
ethan collecting interest on coinbase
now or on
block five you can do it yeah it's
pretty wild
yeah the staking ethereum part is crazy
uh so the fund is it like is it like
they do cash dollars and they just like
invest in crypto yeah it's like a vc
fund got it yeah
yeah there's i ask because uh
the world of like vc and crypto is so
intense i
really didn't understand the scale and
capacity they have it's wild man
the whole it's and it's all happening
under the radar yeah i feel like it's
happening every day and people just
ass coin crypto's a joke man yeah
meanwhile there's a 16 year old getting
rich off of like
butt [ __ ] coin oh yeah dude whatever oh
yeah
anyway sorry to make the same points but
it blows my mind
i love it i love it no and i love sheba
nuts too